Speaker 1: OK, let's see, we're hearing from
people.
That's what we're doing.
We're hearing from people around the country,
around the world, even.
Why don't we try next?
Maybe Steve from Illinois.
Steve, you're on the air.
Speaker 3: Hey, how are you doing?
Speaker 1: I'm doing well, Steve, thank you.
Speaker 3: I have a quick question, a couple
couple weeks ago, maybe, maybe more, maybe
like a month ago, John, Jen Psaki said that
the Obama administration was working with
Facebook to help.
Censor the people they believed for telling
lies about the vaccine, don't you think that's
kind of toeing the line there for government
censorship?
A little bit kind of authoritarianism?
Speaker 1: No, not necessarily.
I mean, listen, we we know that there's about
a dozen people that are the the generators
of the overwhelming majority of the antibiotics
content.
And ultimately, what this comes down to is
Facebook having and enforcing terms of service.
Now I know what you're saying.
It sounds like what you're saying is in practice,
if the government goes to Facebook and says,
ban these people, it's kind of the government
limiting their speech.
That seems to be sort of the analogy you're
making.
Right?
Speaker 3: Or isn't that kind of what they
were?
Do they were they had their team, like the
government team going to Facebook and being
like, hey, this is who we believe.
And I'm not talking about like I'm not saying
that vaccine should be spread thin.
No, I think that they're using.
Speaker 1: And you're saying it's basically
the government censoring people on Facebook.
Speaker 3: Yeah, because we I mean, again,
there's what if I mean, I guy it.
I know you're not happy with what it's like.
The Trump administration is trying to go to
Facebook and saying, hey, we don't think this
is correct.
We should look into banning these people.
Yeah.
So I think there's
Speaker 1: some important there's a couple
of really important things, first of all.
If the Trump administration had done something
like this, it wouldn't have been to prevent.
Empirically invalid claims about vaccines
which lead to death from being made, if it
had been the Trump administration that did
it and they did it about something that was
all about a political agenda, it wouldn't
actually be the same thing.
That's the first thing to understand.
The second thing is the government, as far
as we know, the government provided information
to Facebook about the things that these individuals
were spreading.
And it was up to Facebook to decide whether
it violates the terms of service or not.
Now, if you want to say when the government
tells you, you kind of have to do it, well,
OK, but we don't we don't actually have proof
that that's what went down.
So I understand your concern.
I've not seen any any evidence that there
has been anything other than the government
providing information to Facebook about the
content being put out and Facebook determining
is it OK or not, based on our own terms of
service?
That's my knowledge about it right now.
Speaker 3: No, I guess I'm just using this
slippery slope theory, and then if it's the
other way around, like, I don't think it would
have been even good for any kind of administration
to kind of go on that, because, I mean,
Speaker 1: when you say the other way around,
the problem with you saying the other way
around is it's not the same for the government
to work with Facebook to limit anti vax propaganda
that's killing people versus a Trump administration
to go to Facebook and say you need to ban
anyone who says Joe Biden actually won the
election.
Like, we have to be able to distinguish between
those two things.
Speaker 3: Oh, I guess I'm just the vaccine
is just the example that's used.
I'm saying for future reference, if they're
doing stuff that that the Biden administration
doesn't like, that's being said, I'm moving
forward.
Speaker 1: If that happens, I will be right
here denouncing it if that happens.
Speaker 3: No, I just wanted to see what your
thoughts were on that.
Speaker 1: Yeah, no, I understand.
But unless that I have no reason to think
that that's going to happen.
All right.
All right, my friend, thank you very much,
appreciate the call